[Music]
pete how are you
about your same age dave and i'm
electronically challenged also well
thanks you and i repair brother
we'll try to get through this together
george will help us mit today all right
what's going on here's my question uh
here's my question but i imagine it's
too late to do much
i was coming back through iowa
right before thanksgiving and my duramax
pickup truck broke down went into a
dealership
they put a part on it that was wrong i
end up spending a night in a hotel
i end up having to have someone come get
me i don't give it back until new year's
eve
and as this whole thing went on
they said we got to compensate you
somehow we got to compensate i'm working
with customer service for this company
and they want to give me 100 bucks
and i'm talking to them on my way to go
get the pickup truck and i said
something's got to be settled before i
pick it up or you won't do a darn thing
for me
they put parts on that i didn't need
because the computer told them to
any ideas what i can do today
i'm not very happy
uh without your authorization
i mean that did you not have you didn't
have a discussion with them while the
repair was going on
well yeah the computer said this is the
part it needs
so i said what do i have a choice
and then well no now it was this part
the computer said it needed
and the computer was totally wrong they
called the engineers and the engineers
didn't know what was wrong with it the
technician found the part on his own
and i get a 6 800 repair bill before i
get paid for before i can drive it out
of there
whoa
yeah
i had called uh
ford and dodge i emailed them and asked
if they wanted to trade me pickup trucks
i'd give them this one we could do a
commercial that brand x had a pickup
they didn't know how to fit
man this is a bad situation so you got
so the
service department not only did not i
mean you had no idea this bill was this
high
no
i knew the first thousand dollar part
and then
ah
the parts that it took to finally fix it
they claimed was three thousand dollars
which the service department i can't
really complain with them
because they did what the company
computer told them to do
you know they plugged it into the
computer as they do nowadays
and they the computer was telling them
what parts to put on
but then their own technician their own
technician also
figured out that it that was not what
was wrong with it that was other stuff
he found out eventually it was other
stuff when the engineers at the head
company couldn't figure it out they
threw their arms up
okay so why are they trying to charge
you for parts that did not need to
require the repair then they should just
take it i had to pay
i had to pay the bill before i could
drive it out of there oh so you've
already paid the bill
yeah that i went to get it new uh new
year's eve
yeah okay
they had it five weeks yeah um i guess
what i'm doing is i'm having a
discussion with dodge and i'm having a
discussion with the general manager of
the dealership
uh about a dodge truck huh
it was it wasn't
well i don't want to say okay i don't
care what is it
yes it was a chevy okay i'm sorry you
said duramax so talk so talk to chevy i
mean general motors has good regional
people to deal with complete screw-ups
like this
i worked with uh
lady in customer service the whole time
we talked every week yeah this is beyond
her though this is over her pay grade
because they're gonna need to write you
a check
so somebody's gonna write me a check for
about half of this bill and refund but
it was not needed because i can get i
can put the tech on the uh on the stand
in court and the tech will tell me what
it took to fix the car and that they've
over charged me three thousand dollars
for the parts that weren't needed to fix
the car and then they're going to lose
the case
and by the way general motors nor does
this dealer want to be in court over
overcharging the consumer for this they
just messed up now what they need to do
is make it right
i i the dealership i got no problem with
them i think they went above and beyond
for me they did i got a problem with you
they charged us 6 800 for repair that
should have cost three thousand dollars
but
the computer told them i don't give a
crap what who told them to do it the end
result is they screwed you it's their
responsibility they knew it was
happening
and i'm talking to uh computers don't
run this place people run the place we
tell the computers what to do that's how
life works
so no i i think the general manager and
you need to have a conversation you and
chevy regional not customer service need
to have a conversation and somebody
needs to talk about okay the computer
program the diagnostics are screwed up
and based on your computer program being
screwed up at the uh manufacturing level
manufacturer's level chevy's level
um then you need to you know you guys
did a wrong repair and you overcharge me
and you need to refund me for that and i
don't care if chevy writes the check or
the dealership writes to check i suspect
it'll be chevy because they'll probably
cover for the dealer because the dealer
was doing what chevy told them to do
so
that's i guess is how it'll go down but
i got to tell you man truthfully
i'll be shocked if you don't get some
resolution if you lean in on it
and just make it a very simple thing the
repair should have been around three
thousand dollars based on what the tech
finally found out the tech and the
service bay were misled by a faulty
computer diagno by by a faulty computer
diagnosis that's your all's fault it's
not mine i'm the consumer and you need
to make this right yeah and somebody
needs to write me a check back i
shouldn't be charged for these parts
that were not needed for the repair
that's not right and if you guys don't
make it right then we can make it right
by talking about it on the internet and
put it in you know going to court it's
all gonna be messy it's gonna be a lot
lesser than six thousand dollars for you
and then i'm gonna have to sue you for
like a million because i'm pissed and
you know all this i don't wanna do all
that and it's just not worth it it's
just you guys just because it's chevy
and you guys do the right thing because
i got to tell you what
generally speaking our work working with
people that have had problems over the
years ford
chevy toyota
nissan
they do a good job of doing the right
thing at the corporate level on this
type of situation
they really we don't we don't run into
them just messing people over they just
don't they number one they build a good
product um and number two uh they this
doesn't happen that much and so they
just they have
they've been making customers happy a
long time yeah and you're gonna have to
stand up for yourself financially
advocate for yourself be a little bit
bad cop i don't care they're not your
friends i don't care how nice they were
this is three thousand dollars that they
stole and i don't even care whose fault
it is it wasn't mine
it's one of you guys over here what are
you people messing with my truck i don't
know who it was some of y'all screwed up
and then you overcharged me just send
david and help me hostage yeah i'm going
to hire a new service where dave ramsey
uh fights it that would be fun
that'll be expensive yeah you're right
we can't afford that i'll do it